the BBC has just released a thing which
is something it's called something like
been here all along or something and
it's basically trying to present the
picture of like Britain from 2,000 years
ago being massively populated with black
people this news I shall
impart may not have been told we have
been here from the start B in the
stoneage to war with B
apart before these out British black
people play
their and when people pointed out how
historically inaccurate this is there's
actually a quote from one of the
producers basically saying well we've
got a lie to make it work in the modern
context or something yeah and it's I
never understood this like there's this
phrase uh that again we borrow from
America which is this is a nation of
immigrants I I've read British history
it's not a nation of immigrants it's not
and I'm an immigrant it doesn't make me
feel better that we lie about this how
how why do we do that um I I think the
reason why we do that is because we sort
of don't want to concede any point to
the sort of anti-immigrant
conservative or far right whatever you
want to call them um but I think the
best way to do that is to do it on the
basis of Truth yeah rather than on the
basis of any sort of myth making because
if we concede the truth to sinister
various actors um we are actually doing
a disservice to ethnic minority people
people from immigrant Community
backgrounds um so I think we should
definitely base it on the truth rather
than trying to um feather sort of
respect for um ethnic minority people on
the basis of something which a lot of
people without any kind of ideological
um bias will know to be completely
dishonest and I was curious also what
you made of the there was a recent
incident as we said there literally a
couple of days ago where a black woman
didn't get a refund in a shop that's
owned by a South Asian guy she basically
tried to steal something he took it off
her she started hitting him he fall back
and now this guy's in hiding cuz he's
part of the white supremacist the South
Asian guy is a white supremacist and
going what what are any of you talking
about yeah it's completely yeah it's
it's ridiculous but I think that also
illustrates why terms like Bame b m um
is not you really useful because it
assumes that the experiences and the
values of all ethnic minority people in
the UK are the same when it's obviously
not the case um Asian people can be
prejudiced against black people black
people can be prejudiced against Asian
people and to just assume that any kind
of sort of conflict between these groups
is a consequence of white supremacy is
extremely condescending to these groups
as well yeah and it it's also it's just
deeply
weird it's deeply weird because you look
at these people and you just think to
themselves what are you talking about it
it doesn't make sense when you look at
where this happened is it happened in
pekam and then for those people who've
never been to pekam there's not a lot of
white people there you not going to find
a lot of white supremacy in pekam well
actually there are there there are some
white people but it's it's a certain
kind of white people it's being
gentrified so it's a sort of liberal
youngish Progressive type it's not it's
not the kind of white people you'd
normally associate with white supremacy
yeah um yeah and and and this is it and
and I think this is really what we're
talking about where we what we is that
people are living in a a fictional world
they're living in a world that they
literally go that they go online and
they're being told that this world
exists yes and then they're living in
this world and you go but that is not
reality in any shape or form yes and no
one's denying racism exists of course it
doesn't there were racist people blah
blah blah but that is not the
experience of living in
Peckham yeah exactly and I think that's
one of the things that I try to get
across in my writings is that all too
often when we talk about race and um
discrimination it's done with um it's
done through a very abstract perspective
it's done with a lot of theory a lot of
buzzwords without any reference to the
actual um to use a fashionable term
lived experiences of of of of ethnic
minority people and also white British
people as well um because their
experiences can't simply be reduced to
being victims of racism um and in fact
that kind of perspective to Simply say
that as a black person as an Asian
person your experiences of living in the
UK can be explained entirely through
racism that's that's a completely um I
think that's a profoundly damaging
Distortion of the actual experiences the
actual complex experiences and I think
that also denigrates their Humanity as
well to Simply consider them as purely
victims of racism rather than as complex
fully embodied
people